hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the good joke hour with
Margot lar my name is markiplier and
I've never told a bad joke in my entire
life actually that statement in itself
is a bad joke
so whatever we'll just carry on with it
I'm not here to steal from the king
grumps can do my intro over and over and
over again if you know what I'm talking
about high five to you in the comments
below
way to go you you watch the game drums
just like I do okay so anyway why is
that glowing usually glowy means
something that I need to go - ooh that's
pretty
can I go home now ah no it's just
glowy mushrooms for some reason okay so
why am i Wow that is actually really
cool but why can I go home I just want
to go home even though I kind of am home
aren't I
am I still home like am I still
technically in my castle yeah that's
what I think of my home alrighty then
okay I'm going downwards again this is
not what my daughter told me to do or
wherever the hell Lucy is because
apparently I don't have a daughter
because I don't have time for a daughter
cuz I'm at the egg apparently I yelled
my wife to suicide which makes me even
more of a dick
what is that why is it glowing red okay
all right still going down why am I
going down when are we gonna find this I
bet what we're gonna come across as some
mythic thing or some ritualistic thing
way underground or some portal to Hell
or some [ __ ] like that either way
it's gonna be over hi sorry is it true
your wife commits itself murder oh yes
it is
did I give you permission to speak and
[ __ ] you know what she did to herself
everyone does now proceed with the
transportation of the body and be
careful you should know yourself than
these holes are full of noble graves and
their spirits yeah that's what I thought
I had a sneaking suspicion a little
further oh my god loading dungeon I
think that's the first time there's been
flavor text in one of these loading
screens besides like the picture of
course and also where did these pictures
come from I knew it had to be some sort
of grave or some ritualistic site or
something or some satanic place Oh
prison hidden within the depths of the
castle Holly ancient graves of the
nubile invisible and unimaginable
Nowell spirited men's the courage to
walk these dark shadowed corridors it's
perfect
oh is it perfect good I'm glad
what can when can I get out of here oh
another one okay here we go
oh no that's not another one oh I
thought that was gonna be another one
okay but either way bad things are about
to happen down here is that radio
chatter what is that bizarre sound oh
okay just gonna be on my way now I don't
know what that was but oh man
oh it's bad okay it's bad oh it's bad
why do I have to experience this bull
why do I have to be a part of this I
thought I had a moment to reprieve I
probably did have a moment or reprieve
and that's all I wanted to give me and
then I wanted to throw me right back
into the furnace okay all right okay
we're okay as long as I'm going away
from the months trustee what gizmo Oh am
I just moving bricks on the ground okay
that's fine
are you keeping an eye on that thing
standing behind you because you know you
really can't look at it cuz it's okay
right now I mean it's getting more and
more mad as time goes on but if you turn
around and look at it it's gonna be
really pissed and I'm afraid you might
not survive the encounter if it gets
really upset oh just just just just yes
why did I need to light a match over
right next to a light source okay so
this is good have this where do I use
this
where can I use this for what purpose do
I have this okay that's locked what do I
need this for what do I owe
oh that was bad that's bad knows that
that's bad what am I going what do we do
what do we do go go go go us to think
can I close it close it
okay okay close it myself good oh ho I
don't even know if that was a new thing
you didn't look quite as bulky as the
last one that killed me we might have
been the blind guy okay
dang I can hear the desperate screams of
the prisoners scraping the dry inside of
their throat it's the result of this
delightful process ah I'm a bit of an a
bag it's ten times worse than a d-bag
I'm like kind of worse than Alexander
because I seem to be doing this for pure
evil reasons whereas Alexander of
brennenburg he just wanted to go home he
wasn't of this world and he just wanted
to go home then again you know it's odd
because after I experienced what
happened in amnesia I never actually
delved any oh hey how's it going you
look good and by that I mean screw you
wait was he writing something got that
noise is weird it literally sounds like
an alien message or something
someone's trying to abduct me
chests over there
it's definitely chest I gotta be careful
also I'm gonna run smack into the
monster okay never mind
bye bye bye Mike Mike Mike anything up
there I need probably not okay Mike wait
can I get up there I saw this ladder I
do this this is for here is this for
just like an easter egg or something oh
oh I thought it was gonna be God that
was close
ah so almost happy no okay I get it I
get it I'm not as smart as I thought I
am oh maybe it's all that oh come on I
saw it here damn it
okay fine you win this round
I gotta find where to go and the problem
is like I don't know if I'm gonna miss a
door or something because it's really
hard to differentiate we have I this
looks weak can I pass that down possibly
could a monster pass that down could it
be a monster bash okay bricks bricks
just bone fine BAM okay that was a
fruitless task of course it wasn't gonna
work why did I even bother why did I
need to come down there okay so I think
this is a way that I was going whoa whoa
hey Wow
did not notice that before hello sir how
are you doing I'm trying to get by
doesn't seem to be working okay thank
you oh oh there was another path down
here I just didn't see it I'm a dingus I
could have gone around at any time well
never mind me I'm just a maroon house
like wander oh hey
I did how's it been okay nevermind
freaking out shovel fine oh come on
where do I gotta go now
what do you want from me game what do
you want from me what do you want from
me okay
okay I think I think we gotta be getting
close to like an end of some sort here
why do I need to crawl into more
exploiting closed spaces oh good I don't
okay never mind then I mean I've been
kind of skirting on the edge of losing
all my matches but all I need to know is
this why why why why more blocked off
routes why can't you just tell me where
I need to go because obviously I can't
see it wait why why why why why
Oh what do i do what do I do oh I'm bone
I'm on I'm on I'm on whoa oh oh okay
fine hi nice up okay bye okay alright
let's got a run just gotta run gotta run
oh he's fast
he sounds fast he might not be fast he's
fast
Oh what is this white why why now what's
happening why I'm dying
what the hell happened once
is that supposed to happen okay all
right oh oh I'm being carried oh okay
all right so that was supposed to happen
okay we're fine I guess wish you would
tell me before it does something like
that cuz otherwise I'm gonna be confused
and think I did something wrong
all right what are you going oh whoa
hello why am I here where is Lucy why do
I care about Lucy am I even the Baron
am i the baron I don't know oh hey oh oh
hey hey hey how's your uh your friend
pick me up I was really drunk and I just
came need the place to crash okay maybe
I'm not the baron that's I don't know
seems like the shadow lady definitely
wants to murder my face but you never
know about these things could be just a
big misunderstanding Hey Dude how's it
going
feeling good I'll leave you be you look
like you're having fun I wouldn't want
to intrude
okay so wow they're smart enough to
actually lock me
sorry I didn't mean to compliment you we
mean hi what do you mean hide what do
you mean hide hope where we gonna hide
where we gonna head oh can I hide in his
body
oh oh oh oh I don't know I don't know oh
[ __ ] uh-uh-uh-uh who's dead back there
okay wait a minute open it up
I should've put the bed back okay okay
I'm okay I escaped I escaped I made it
out of your safely came okay it's like
the escape it's all over again I get out
of here I don't know if I can like the
bed got screwed up
that sounds really bad by the way
oh oh oh oh oh oh he's above me oh
that's why it sounds bad
duh okay so he smashed through here okay
he's master here which leads to
somewhere which means I can go somewhere
else oh this is where I was looking at
him okay I got it I got it so yeah over
here
can I get some more Matt's matches any
matches okay am I supposed to go that
way or am I supposed to go I guess
either one is fine
they're probably the Sonos oh okay
there's got to be a way to go what is
that a murder well or something well for
all your blood that's really weird
covered all right cool cool cool
oh no this is where he is I'm almost out
of matches this Bad News Bears
Oh
oh [ __ ] I'm dead I'm dead from that he's
my music always right back oh he's
definitely right by me oh oh was he not
maybe he was not yeah that's weird huh
whoa oh there yeah yeah yeah how about
that
oh crap that was a bad idea
I could have stuck by why did I run
can't see can't see can't see oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
ah what is that oh I know what that is I
put that there
okay so I just got to go back the way I
came because I got something tell is it
I can't I have no idea what I got I got
something I remember I got something
from the other end of there so now I'm
back over here this is where I was is
where I got captured so if I go over
here there should be something else that
I can have some way to go please tell me
this is open please do I get a key why
don't I have a key
where was I supposed to get a key oh
maybe I can that so what that is dammit
okay fine okay
well what is going on whoa oh hey hey
hey hey
hey how you doing okay all right cool
why that wasn't heat that was really
cool I'm glad that happened okay
are you doing no no no no no no no no no
no no no
okay I came him okay alrighty then
okay all right okay all right okay this
baloney I gotta find this key or
something damn it's Jesus okay all right
I think I gotta go back into the area
with the other dude not that I know
where that was oh I do know where that
was okay
oh oh oh my god I can't believe that
that was so not obvious okay all right
then sorry sorry sorry I that took so
long to find I had no idea I didn't see
it at all gracefully me and my own
sisters take our turns to torment he's
poor
Oh gracefully the nobles mental torture
has proven to be even more effective
than my physical one but the prisoners
have yet to experience the consolidation
of both this will earn my ancestors
respect Oh cautions keep us fulfilled
oh my dear yes I'm still running very
very low on manses but I am all out of
time for this part because I have
wandering around for like 30 minutes
trying to find well supposed to do is it
hole in the ground how would I bow to no
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the other amnesia
custom stories and scare games I've done
in the description below or in the
annotations over there thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
the fish